How many, what percentage of people like
to be peed on? It's got to be below 1%.
That's still a lot.
It's 300 million people.
That means 3 million
people or to get peed on.
That's just in this country alone.
That's a lot of pee clean up.
You know what I mean?
I don't even think it's 1%,
but even if it's one 10th
of 1% is 300,000 people.
Like I love a chocolate Sundae,
but if you smeared it all over the place,
then the after the clean up I probably
back. You know, I'm not into that. Yeah.
Think what do you, what do you went
to? It's a freakish thing you're into.
I'm surprisingly tame.
I'm not in anything freaky.
I've never even done like
whip cream or anything.
Mm Hace what about when a girl
asks you to like choke or a little,
how do you feel about that?
Um, that's a scary request.
I'm not into that. I'm not. Um, I had
a girl that I used to date who, uh,
wanted me to rape her. She
told me the raper that's, hmm,
that's tough and problem.
When she was fucking hot and I was like
I do not want to get interested in doing
this. Like the, the, the worst
thing would be you really liked.
Yeah cause I was in my twenties.
What if,
what if I just had it came up then I got
into like only girls that want you to
like force them to do shit.
And that's, that's very true.
When you are young and you're
forming your sexuality,
whatever you first got your like when
I first dance with a girl and I noticed
her hips were wide.
I,
I got like a boner and there's like an
eighth grade cause it was like this is,
she's different link and four years till
I was like in my early thirties I could
not dance with a girl
without getting a hard on.
I was at a wedding once and I asked
this girl to dance, I never do this.
But she was like alone and she was
hot and I got on the dance floor,
my mother's there and I got like a boner.
I don't know this girl at all. And
I had to tell her, cause you know,
you know like your wedding
pants are not keeping things no.
And so full pitched and I, she probably
already knew. So I was like, I'm sorry,
can you help me off off the floor?
And I had to how humiliating it says I'd
asked this girl to like Shimmer me off
the floor away from my
mother. Yeah, she had a good,
luckily a good sense of humor about it,
but it was luck ameliorating. Well she,
well I shouldn't say she
should be flattered but a
grownup, but sense of humor,
if you flattered. She invited to
her Halloween party after that,
which is a good sign. But that went bad.
I, I got all dressed up as the universe.
Like I, I, yeah,
I had like a whole black outfit and I
glued like planets to my body with velcro
and then grown man.
And then I go to her house on time,
which I didn't realize that you
don't go to parties on time.
I just gotten to La and then
I went and I went to hug her.
I knocked over the skeleton on the wall
and there were a dog ran up and like bit
Venus off my leg and took off and I'm
just in the room and no one's dressed up.
People are coming and they're like,
have a bad day. It's like I'm a pirate,
but no one's really dressed
up except for a meal.
So I was a pariah and then no one taught
me, say put the at the end, this guy,
because all our friends were like, frat
guys. He goes, can I ask you a question?
And I was like, yeah, like I want someone
to talk to me. He goes, you a faggot? No,
yeah, no. It was like
really? Yeah. Was like,
now I'm in is all started with me getting
a boner with this girl. But anyway,
I gotta go and Jesus Christ what a Dick.
Yeah,
it was kind of a dick. Was
he a dick before that? Yeah,
they were all kind of like a
jockey jockey and they were drunk.
And I think I seem like a target
cause I had the universe, uh,
on my body seemed like an
easy target. Yeah. But that's,
that's a severe weakness.
Unless you were doing something. I mean,
why wouldn't they think that was funny?
Like what are you doing man?
What's with the outfit?
And then he started talking and you start
laughing. Everybody has a gate. Yeah,
we would have had a good time.
Yeah, you went right. Yeah.
Yeah. You know that's funny
though. The boner thing. Yeah.
Cause there was a girl that I dated
when I was in high school and she,
she was into like rubbing her feet on me
and I had a foot thing for a long time
because of it. What, where was she
rubbing her feet idea? I mean that
I meant like where are you at your house,
school or whatever.
She would just rubber feet on my legs
and put her feet on my girlfriend. Yeah.
Yeah. I used to go to this
math class, 10 30 ugly teacher,
but her smell boner every time.
And I knew, I was like, ah,
I gotta go get a boner in this class.
That's hilarious.
But that is a real thing
about like getting connected
to like a particular like
thing, like whether it's choking
someone or any of that guy. That girl,
the girl wanted me to rape her.
Also would grab my hand
and put it on the back row,
like get me to force her head down.
She was crazy.
She was just really into it,
but it took a while for her to warm up.
It's almost like when we first started
fooling around, she's like, come on,
don't tell him this mother
fucker what I like normal.
And then one day she wanted
to Russell. Okay. Yeah.
She's like warm rustic
gateway draws like what?
She's like when a Russell you I've
put on kick your ass. I was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Like what are you doing?
You just beat her up. You
lost. I didn't, I didn't,
I didn't beat her up,
but I was trying to figure out what
we're doing while we're doing it and she
turned it sexual. She got into it. Yeah.
I think like, like Louis C K I like,
I remember he's show like one of the
first episodes he had a show rogue,
an older girl asked him to jerk off in
front of her. And I was always like,
I bet that actually happened.
And that got linked up.
You can't really decide what
links up your sexuality,
what it is a turns on.
It just could have,
I have no information. But that's my
guess. If people are into weird shit man,
what are in the weird shit I
ended the weirdest is this,
is this smelling the shoes.
Oh
Marla maples trumps x.
Put a camera in her bedroom because she
kept in her closet cause she kept losing.
She did have one shoe and it
was some friend would come in,
they got the economy just like just
coming in and stealing sniffing or she's
Christ has zakat linked
up. Ah. Anyway. Yeah,
there's a lot of that stuff, right?
Like stealing underwear, stealing shoes.
Yeah. Men are, the thing is, I
mean men get picked on cause we're,
we're pervs and that's,
it's true.
But if we weren't pervs this species
wouldn't be, or let me tell you why.
Because we were down
to like 70,000 people.
If we didn't have this super
per game to go through the snow,
get some pussy I think is
less than 70,000 people.
They were saying that after one of the
super volcanoes it might've gotten down
to is it's just a few thousand ma.
Well,
there's a definite, what does it Sumatra?
Is that where it was? Indonesia? Some,
some massive supervolcano
70,000 years ago.
Killed off almost everybody.
Oh, I didn't know about that.
We got down to extremely low number.
I think they estimate it's somewhere
between like two and maybe like 10,000
people. Yeah. You need people who liked
off bug a lot that are real curvy, curvy,
jump that up. Well, you know,
Bret Weinstein, who is a, yeah,
he was a professor. Sorry. What's going
on man? I smoked weed before the show.
I'm not going to lie
to people. Um, he, um,
was explaining with his
wife who's also a biologist,
that there's two different
things that men are attracted to.
They're attracted to a beautiful woman,
but they're attracted to a hot woman.
Like a hot woman doesn't
necessarily have to be beautiful,
but what she does is offer an
opportunity for like very quick sex.
Like you could just have sex with her.
You don't have to court her like a girl
with a short skirt and her tits are
popping out and she's wearing a lot of
makeup that what that signals is that
there's an opportunity for you to
spread your genes and you have no
responsibility. You wouldn't have to
take care of it. You wouldn't have to,
you wouldn't have to spend a lot of
time with her court her that she was,
she's the type of person that
allows you to just fuck her.
You can move on and spread your genes
elsewhere. That makes sense. Yeah,
that there's a like an evolutionary
reason for that being a stimulating thing
for men.
Like for men,
like this idea of like these loose women
like loose women are very attracted,
very attractive to us for that reason.
It's not just that like, oh yeah,
if I get some not deal with
all these bitches in there. No.
It's literally an evolutionary trait that
we have adapted to the disease thing.
Knocks it back a little bit for me.
I'll go like,
oh my big disease there is,
I have anecdote,
anecdote and antidote for cause I don't
feel like there's any woman who could,
no matter how hot like come and and and,
and uh,
take me away or like a force me to like,
what am I trying to say?
Seduced me. Why you're here. It is,
I think a woman could seduce you now if
I don't want her to. I have an anecdote,
anecdote
I haven't handed out and it's,
I've been developing it over
years and people can uh,
listening can take this if you like,
let's say you fell for
somebody and she didn't like,
and she jumped you and you're still
pining over her. Put her first.
You'd like think about like the blood
moving through her body and her and her
skeleton and you put her on the toilet.
You think about like she's making by,
I know it's gross,
but that's,
you think about her as this animal and
you think about her on the toilet and you,
whenever she pops up, you put her
on the toilet. You're welcome.
That doesn't work with me. It
will. I won't care. No, no, no.
If I think she's hot,
but she's really struggling on the toilet,
I struggle on the toilet
so you can bond over that.
I take, I eat a lot, man.
I'd take some horrific shits.
But think about like the Bachelorette
or something. They're there.
Fantasize a lot of times early
on there's like this fantasy and,
and uh, you know your, your
marriage. Yes. So you're, you have,
there's intimacy and
you get past all that,
but that early on fantasy make filling
in the blanks as perfect person.
You usually leave that out.
It never bothered me. I don't,
I don't give a fuck about periods. What
about, I'm thinking about their skeleton,
anything? Does that kind
of go oh yeah, yeah.
If you just imagine there's a skeleton
underneath this woman that I'm like
pining over. She's just like, all right,
this doesn't work. It doesn't work on
me. It works for me to tell you, man,
if I think someone's hot,
I think they're hot.
I don't care if they just took
a diary of Shit. How about this?
I imagine they have bad
breath. I'll be like, God,
but she has bad breath and I'd tell her.